[Music]
okay three two one welcome to
off-the-record we talked about whatever
the hell we want
Oh guys [ __ ] people women I love women
nice yeah you're the guy who uses that
angle to get laid
I was doing the the guy that leaves the
comments where he's like you know what
men are all trash yeah I thought that
you know [ __ ] it men are kind of like
all trash thanks it's a good angle so
you up my angle dude you did you took my
love you what actually facts yeah it's
fun though cuz married guys don't need
angles anymore it's all fun now yeah
true it's like hey man I'm out the game
it's like what do I even need to you
know look what do I do need to bathe for
anymore that's why I think we should we
should do because I've been watching a
lot of pick-up channels on YouTube cause
I just find pickup cultures so [ __ ]
funny oh my god but nobody's ever done a
married dudes pick up women thing
because it's almost like we're fishing
and then we're just throwing them back
let the wedding ring on oh yeah we no no
no we take it off for the video but but
we just throw them back the whole time
yeah you just whatever we pull we throw
back but we do it to show young men how
to get women cuz cuz in pickup shows
it's always like single dudes trying to
score chicks right and they're nervous
and they're panicky and they don't know
what the [ __ ] we've all scored hot
chicks like all of us yeah so it's like
we should be given the advice true like
we now don't even want it anymore you
know ii mean like you don't want i mean
you don't want other women like you're
just kind of like they're just kind of
like jaded like oh you're probably gonna
be trouble
yeah but this isn't this isn't processes
for them this is for you to teach that
EG like to go off what you're saying I
feel like as a married man now it'd
probably be like really easy you know
I'm saying
something is like you got a woman at
home right so like you're just chilling
and you're like I'll talk and be [ __ ]
I won't get embarrassed man because I
think about it one thing behind seems
like if you keep it real I mean a lot
you'd be surprised at how many not only
girls but like guys
well of course guys but a lot of girls
would be down to mess with a married
dude you know I'm saying as long as you
don't like live but I feel like if a
guy's in a relationship or married or
value goes up wait a min are crazy girls
actually get turned on by watching even
more because we're scusi no there's an
article where I was like I think I think
dudes we're trying to pick up on chicks
with the wedding ring and because they
have it on the girls walls that they
usually have so you saw the call you
never defend their walls the other
defend is already down interest so now
they're just two normal people having a
conversation and they can like oh it is
- there's no expectations and there's
there's no games or expectations cuz
you're like you know what this dude
wants running I'm saying you're not you
don't have to be like does he want a
relationship does he just want to plug
does he want this it's like oh he's
married he definitely isn't looking for
marriage all right maybe he just wants
this and if that's what she wants then
it's like cool why not
you know zan yeah or it's like they see
you with your partner and they go wow I
want a guy like that maybe I'll just
steal him away like what Nicki did to
you true true
Nicki got all well what did she saw you
with other girl yeah
well [ __ ] that she swooped in as soon as
I was saying oh she just swooped right
in Ashley knew must look like 32 hours
and [ __ ] on this 70 seconds oh yeah he
came at me [ __ ] first like her leg
like a horror movie opening Luke a [ __ ]
attack - yeah she's like a headcrab in
that half video my god do you like
dating life we'll just see you are
that's our movie we need that movie
about you and Nikki like flying it is
what happened to Lu Kang dude the
bicycle kick and she's similar body
shape and size features look at deep sea
squid yeah so I was already and it was
weird cuz our first time together I feel
like I can tell you guys this cuz I were
close and I've known you for a [ __ ]
decade mm-hmm
you're the first time we were together I
had only been with my ex so like I
actually sexually so for like you know
five years or four years yeah there's a
long time so then it's like this is my
first girl in like four years it's like
not the my ex chick and then I was just
so nervous the whole time I couldn't do
much so I felt like really foreign and
like you can get it up yeah oh do you
that I mean that's happened right where
it's like you're never never not seen
not to me man what are you talking about
Lud
I've been there you start crying hey all
my all my lip dig dudes out here it
happens I it definitely happened to me
where I've been like been wanting this
master chick for so long because I
thought she was so hot I don't get
nervous mad nervous and when we actually
got there it's like [ __ ] man I can't get
it up yeah whatever did you like them so
much you put them on a pistol and you're
like okay before too much stress you
just got to go in the basket a pep talk
it up and get mad at it like wow yeah
how did you come back out hey guys I'm
ready I get a little hey I'll be good
but then like you ever like run into it
that's like nah I don't I don't want to
do that and then it's like warm me up
I'm like there's the [ __ ] door I'm
serious dude I think seriously I'm like
no [ __ ] are a part of life life
already sucks pretty much a lot of ass
so if I don't get [ __ ] in this life
that I live in is just sucking ass I'm
out it's definitely [ __ ] up you know
you know and and mutually - because
you're a giver as well you got a warm
each other up right like I feel like
that's just how that [ __ ] works and I've
definitely dealt with chicks in the past
where it's happened where they're like
like no I don't give hand is like what's
wrong with you are you are you all right
are you dumb the 1870s and I in the
crucible movie right now is going on he
what be the Sun he did exactly what time
I heard this girl say like I think it's
degrading and I was like well I'll
[ __ ] eat well yeah I'll even eat your
ass like exactly like that's not the
grating
it's empowering because I'm [ __ ]
controlling your [ __ ] senses oh well
then it's the grating yes I mean like oh
[ __ ] I shouldn't set anything yeah
you lose and you lose but you got to rev
the engine though I think it goes both
ways right I mean so your line that
you're drawing is if you're with
somebody everything is good and then she
goes you know what I don't think like a
suck dick I could be in love to the
fullest degree I'm right there with your
harps and violins when I see her I am
chucking her in the [ __ ] River
if she doesn't suffer I'm serious
because there's no because that's facts
because a girl not sucking dick and I
wish it all of you well not only that
goes the same way with a guy that
wouldn't eat the [ __ ] right yes it goes
the same way it's about not it's not
it's not that like oh it's like oh it's
like you gotta suck my dick like a power
thing it's like that person it shows
that they're not willing to like
sacrifice and compromise you for you you
know I'm saying it's like symbolic of
how their mind you know what mine is so
there's the dick sucking with a [ __ ]
eating of course but the next step that
I also attached to it I have to be able
to see or take the [ __ ] okay
completely open so for me on my butt is
that sexual for you no it's not sexual
no I'm just saying like in terms of the
love I love feeling the love and the
marriage thing it's not sexual at all
but I'm like who doesn't suck dick these
days everyone sucks like we're all we
all have microphones were onstage at a
seminar and you just like you're [ __ ]
Bush hates black people did how long did
it take for you to CG or [ __ ] then no uh
yeah house you have to force his way in
the bathroom was kind of shy so I have
to like most people take this [ __ ] but
now it's completely cool she shits in
front of me yes how long will that take
why is that so important to you for me
you know what it is I think it's a
psychological mental thing it's like
okay party know if I already know you
can suck my dick that's over and done
with
what are your deepest darkest
insecurities expose that to me then I
trust you Marty you are a hooker well I
can't wait dude if you in this dinner if
you weren't with Gio I can't wait for
you to write a tinder profile oh my god
cards like if I can't put on a mining
helmet flip on the lights and go like
this to your [ __ ] with a bright light
then you don't [ __ ] trust me if you
won't [ __ ] in a bucket and let me play
with it and make a [ __ ] castle we
ain't in love not too crazy because
because Chea my wife she all wanted to
see you she always just be like what she
owes me like babe let me just take a
shower while you taking a [ __ ] I'm like
no that is my time let me take a [ __ ]
were there multiple bathrooms in your
hell
no it was one bathroom and she just
wanted to be in the bathroom with me
while I was it smell I I know but she
was like she's like babe just let me I'm
like no maybe when we're married you
know I'm saying and now you have to do
it and then well now well we would but
except for like we asked so many
bathrooms now I just like look I'm like
leave me alone bro but like yeah you can
come see me [ __ ] I'm gonna take a [ __ ]
right now and then she's like cause it's
a grant Rama and I'm sitting in the
closet
sitting a transvestite did farting like
I wanna be a little don't hold back man
live life I disagree you know like party
it ruins it for me cuz I got two
bathrooms before you guys move into the
house we first got together like the the
like the first couple months we were to
go like after IDI night like right on
his function how did she take it that
first thought was she like she was just
very cool with that she was so super
cool it's awesome because I was very
weird and nervous and [ __ ] yeah and
Nikki still understanding oh she's
really cool and then the next night she
was like holy [ __ ] this is awesome
that's awesome did you take revenge on
the first night I did I was so pissed at
myself like I went into the bathroom and
I had an angry podcast with my cell
phone I was never so de 89 I am Steve
rain you son of a stupid [ __ ] Jude I
was so [ __ ] brought to you by [ __ ]
him like what actually happened in there
what the [ __ ] going on it's like
talking back to you he's like huh no man
you just froze up oh dude and then I was
sweating so much cuz I was nervous like
I was just hot really get too hot it was
because you were with the same girl for
so long yeah yeah yeah I'm very long
that she just [ __ ] Luke aid you with
that [ __ ] it was so unexpected yeah see
I understand it that she came on too
strong we're ready for my signal that
[ __ ] and then I wasn't ready for it
yeah and then you know her labia studied
the fist like this
I think of the lady you're doing this
coming at me exactly no [ __ ] sea
urchin quality on the ocean floors your
Star Wars creatures and like alien then
the clip the clip does the Scorpion but
then you you laid it down let it down
the next time it brought me back cuz I
was like oh my god how fast this how
fast does she wanna [ __ ] after you guys
got together Oh second date
you shall talk we should call your dick
Red Dead Redemption
it's Red Dead Redemption - pink dead
redemption wasn't the first one my dick
died weekend at Bernie's yeah do you
guys get that whiskey dick yeah I don't
drink so if I drink anything I can [ __ ]
no problem
mines mines a time bomb so if I drink I
probably have like the first 30 minutes
to an hour and then afterwards I pass
out of my dick passes out - no just do
you go to sleep yeah so I'm just my
whole body doesn't work is your dick
awake past you and then he passes out
yes so I go to sleep with like a hard-on
yeah and then it slowly fades away -
it's so real because I've had those
nights where it's like yo you're so
drunk
you're mad horny and then you trying to
get in and it's like it's like what if I
get it on the first 30 minutes it works
really it's just like I don't even know
if the alcohol is hit you by then yet
though cuz like for me it takes like
really I think I'm so sensitive to it so
when I drink it like I'll get really
horny and then it's super rock hard and
then like it's like oh like a Jewish
accountant your dicks your angry wife
doing anything
whenever my new friend [ __ ] Carson
kid I know but I mean again all I need
is a little bit of head and I'm me too
man
that's why I'm saying whiskey dick
because Nikki's so cool like that yeah
even if I have like a whiskey dick
situation Nikki got her head in the game
she's still helping you out
exactly see and that's the best when you
when the girls understanding of that
because like I've had the situation a
situation where it's like softened up
because of the whiskey dick and she was
like and she was like oh no I get it
whiskey dick no wow yeah I'm saying so
it's like oh that's teamwork yeah yeah
but mentally I'm not raging at you I'm
raging kind of like no no warning oh I'm
so [ __ ] horny like let's do this thing
what's [ __ ] up is when a girl like
blames herself when you're like yeah she
gets all unsecured it things like she's
not hot enough oh you're gonna peel you
know have a conversation like this
already saw you naked right I'm like wow
yeah I'm like why are you Mila Kunis in
a rom-com the shower school oh my god
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude I saw
you naked yes you make it everyday I
don't get that anymore well I don't get
what whiskey-dick no I mean like the shy
that making shine naked shy you don't
get it
oh he does it to me all the time as
though oh yeah well cuz she and she's
not ready for me to see her then she
doesn't like it
yeah oh you ready for me to see her and
then she's just then I think that's cool
cuz then you guys are always presenting
yourself in the best way possible and
that's what I think about the bathroom
thing where I I just don't I don't fart
around her I don't [ __ ] on her and I'ma
be around her do you fart no dude so
it's more of like a courtesy thing than
more than anything else is a good yeah
it's like trying to be like I I want I
mean I know that we can do like show
each other our you know darkest side bar
my whole logic minded is that I'm always
trying to date her yeah okay that's you
and so if I keep that going buddy dope
it's only gotten more intense like we're
more into each other now than we were
when we got together like in every
aspect of our lives so I feel like this
is the main reason why go [ __ ] guys
try this method
giggling die don't work on I want you to
go lay on a sword outside right now you
son of a [ __ ] Oh David I'm cool I like
[ __ ] and chips oh wait so did Nikki
ever like she did she ever like fart in
front you and you were like that would
be great it's never happened I wanna see
what really ever happened that's pretty
[ __ ] good let me tell you man me and
Shiah
it's like [ __ ] like a like a band
practice is about the tune up for the
snow god she doesn't pull often for
image it's extinct you you want to talk
about something weird did I told this to
the other day yeah he threw a bean bag
at Chia dude from upstairs dude tears I
was dying back a little bit better be
mature I just see this guy come up I see
it what's he doing and then BOOM full
bean bag at it oh my god that should had
be dying they should knock her out
follow me on instagram do it on myself
before i threw it over the balcony and
you tested it that's good she can take
it yeah and then after she woke up from
her like confession how's being married
it's a dope actually yeah I was just
sometimes I fit and I'm like like man
this is this is cool like I wake up and
like after I like I take a [ __ ] she's
like hey I made you breakfast and like
she makes me uh I drink more water I go
to bed earlier I think my skin is
clearing up my god it's just nice it's
more it's the structure I need it you do
it me when I was all over the place
before yeah I got a lot of [ __ ] done but
at the same time like she kind of keeps
me in order you know don't you tell you
know you got a come on by this time too
so it helps you kind of like get all
your work done at a certain amount of
time um not really but she will be like
she'd be like hurry home tonight you
know I'm like okay babe
right oh I like that so that's cute yeah
not like you have to come home at this
time
yeah can she can she cook pretty well
she um she's good at trying out recipes
that she sees and then
like then they come out tasty so yeah
and then she's here from Canada so how
how is like a friend the friend
situation because she wouldn't know as
many people are here I mean well luckily
um you know she's cool the few my
friends are cool you know so and and my
friends of friends are cool so she's
kind of like built relationships just
cuz people my friends our friends really
enjoy her so she's kind of began to
build relationships and and also like um
she's got a tight homegirl here someone
she could confide in and not yet that's
important yeah I know
she talked to her friends back at home
she talks to him all the time and and
and also the thing is all of her friends
back home Bale moved out of that city to
dance so she doesn't feel like he sucks
ah yeah yeah leave so no one fits oshi
doesn't feel like all my friends are
there and I'm like and I miss them it's
like everyone kind of graduated from
that city so they all kind of got it
yeah yeah that makes sense
that's what happened to Jess - none of
our friends are back in the hometown
oh so she doesn't want to go back to
even if she wanted like it's like
there's no friend girl I'd never lived
with the girl that I've been with Wow oh
you're in for a treat I know just
collecting your guys's beginning stories
and preparing myself because it's gonna
take that it's actually lit okay it's
cool she just gets mad at me for like
apparently I don't close drawers ever oh
it's only been less than a year it's
been like a couple months but you also
don't really get pissed ever you'll have
a bad temper right nah have you guys
never had a fight with yell at each
other we don't yell but we've had a
couple fights yeah but I don't think
we've ever do you ever do that [ __ ] is
silent yell [ __ ] dude what's like what's
that one like one of these things is
like yeah I mean because sometimes like
I try not to yell but that she'll come
out it was like the intensity yeah like
the intensity is right here in these two
[ __ ] fingers you know maybe like just
like this damn you channel all your hate
into little one little come on like if
Isis when powers this would be the
sharpest [ __ ] laser on it it's
spreading out of this big dude I've done
this thing that maybe I've done twice
and I I feel like in the moment I think
it looks nuts like so scary and [ __ ] but
I think in reality like it's like
basically going like this
like so to me it's like you just won the
[ __ ] Super Bowl I think I'm a fan of
a band or something but it's not so it's
not that good or threatening but in the
moment I'm like oh I just blew my lid
bro she's like she's they're cracking up
yeah right that's like she like he's
doing that stupid little cheer exactly
can't be taken seriously I got mad too
much
I got a practice to chill really I don't
know how do you do it to him how do you
do it come here I just I don't know I
just don't like if you if I'm if I'm
bothered you can tell like I get well I
get very like it should be like Phoebe
are you mad I'm like and then that's
when she knows I'm pissed if you've got
to say well I'm good and then she's like
she's like man she starts feeling bad
because she knows that P is there
anything that pisses you off yeah but
you have to realize to the type of woman
that he's with also reciprocates his
calm is back to him right
so the type of women that I feel like we
are with they're very [ __ ] feisty
dude so it's not like she comes out of
like what about the you know she doesn't
know that so he that energy matches each
other like we're feisty boys and we
feisty girls end up with feisty women so
yeah if she's pissed at me she just
won't talk to me
I get the opposition sometimes we pray
for that yeah yeah but that's why this
is so nice cuz right now none of us are
getting our [ __ ] balls busted
it's so nice fun day I'm like I just
told a story and nobody broke my balls
about it instead like it didn't happen
like that that is like that is the
girl's specialty right there he's like
don't be with a bunch of friends right
you'll never back through that we're
playing ball and I felt lease ain't that
three no you did it and she just walks
away why what did that do for you it's
like they wait for an opportunity to
bring you down yeah they do it's like
hmm
I love [ __ ] you up now my school
[Music]